I'm extremely pleased the law is  actually making three things possible  the first thing is that is connecting  the animal welfare and in their good  husbandry animal health with a human  health and by doing that by making the  direct link it will actually cause the  more much more restrictive use of  antibiotics the second thing that is  making possible it is focusing and  making it possible for both authorities  and producers to focus on a prevention  and to combat the spreading of dangerous  trust transmittable diseases and the  third thing we have actually managed to  kind of to put 40 different legal acts  down to the one single and have very  happy member states has up with  Australian animals as well it is  actually giving them the opportunity  possibility impunity to make  vaccinations to companies the spread of  diseases to make the possibility of  having the national register and so on  and so everything that the member states  have demanded for the stray animals  you